more than a hundred thousand covid19
cases were recorded in the uk in the
last 24 hours it is the first time the
number of daily infections passed that
milestone since mass testing began the
sharp rise is being driven by the rapid
spread of the omicron variant with
governments and their advisors waiting
for data on the severity of the new
strain
today a very small study in scotland
suggested that the risk of
hospitalization was two thirds lower
than with the delta variant let's have a
look now at the latest infection figures
and 106
122 new cases of covid19 were reported
today that's a 140 more people have died
as well taking the number of people who
have died within 28 days of a positive
covert test to 147
573.
968
665 new boosters or third jabs were
given yesterday with first and second
doses taking it to a new record of more
than a million vaccines done in a single
day
it all means
point eight four million people have now
had their third jab or
booster
skies sadia chaudhary is in the newsroom
and we'll talk about uh child vaccines
in a moment sally first of all this data
and another milestone has been passed
yes two records there one good and one
perhaps not so good let's start with the
good that's the
vaccine rollout
that new record that
you've just mentioned and of course it's
not surprising we've all seen the queues
i've been to some of these vaccine
centers myself to report and i've spoken
to people and there was this sense of
urgency to try and get vaccinated before
christmas because people want to be safe
for christmas they want to make sure
that they're not infecting their family
members when they see them so there was
this massive push and i think that
explains why we're seeing this new
record as you say of over a million
vaccines
given out today the vast majority of
them uh boosters but then there's a bad
record too and that is the uh over a
hundred thousand new cases and let me
just mention here that there is a
difference between cases and infections
of course cases are those people who
have reported and have tested positive
for covid but you know infections are
people who might may have been infected
may have been asymptomatic so we don't
know what that number is but certainly
it's a worrying number and if we had
thought that things were going to
plateau then we were wrong because that
number seems to be growing now i'll just
tell you last wednesday's figure the
number of new cases last wednesday was
78
610 and at that time that was the
highest number of infections since the
start of the pandemic and at that time
nhs england's chief executive said that
that number should worry us all so now
we're above a hundred thousand i wonder
what he would say to that
right and uh no mass vaccination of five
to 11 year olds but vulnerable children
of that age will get a jab yes so this
new formulation of the fisa biontech
vaccine has been approved by the uk's
medicines and healthcare products
regulatory agency the mhra and that
means that some children will be allowed
to get the pfizer vaccine and as you say
the majority of children of that age
group between 5 and 11 are at very low
risk of getting seriously ill from covid
so it will only be those children who
are in a very
clinically sensitive
group or someone who lives with
somebody else who is immunosuppressed so
a very small number of five to 11 year
olds will get to that vaccine and that's
what the jcvi is saying and i'll just
read out to you what the jcvi's kovid
lead professor wei
said
the majority of children aged 5 to 11
are very low risk of serious illness due
to covid19 however some 5 to 11 year
olds have underlying health conditions
that put them at higher risk and we
advise that these children be vaccinated
in the first instance and i can tell you
that a primary course vaccination for
that age group is 2 10 microgram doses
and that is a third of what we adults
get